We can remove a 4 from the first 3 terms of out numerator, leaving us with 4
times x squared plus 4x plus 4. We can also remove a 4 as a greatest common
factor from 4x and 8. This leaves us with 4 times x plus 2 in our denominator.
We have a quadratic trinomial here and not only that it's a perfect square
trinomial, so we can factor that as x plus 2 times x plus 2. Finally, we cancel
the factors in the numerator and the denominator. So x plus two divided by x
plus two equals one, and four divided by four equals one. Remember, we're only
simplifying factors, or things that are being multiplied in our numerator and
our denominator. This leaves us with x plus two divided by one, or just x plus
two. Notice that not every rational expression simplifies to another fraction.
Sometimes we'll just get another polynomial.